like the whole okay when where's someone
all right this is this is controls we'll
take it when someone is like severely
into something like a show you know uh i
was about to describe myself there
actually
i was like because you know you see
these you see these things where like
they make their whole life about
something
right this is me with jojo in it yeah
really yeah yeah
yeah i saw something you know when i
remember watching this show one time and
this woman had like everything in her
life was barbie oh yeah yeah the one
living in l.a right the japanese woman
that's right yeah yeah i've seen it
everything she owned was bobby yeah and
i was like
is this like something that like can
happen to anyone or it's something that
like
he he said he he ponders while his jojo
posters are in the background with the
jojo's statue
and the ten thousand dollar jojo
wearing his jojo suit listen i i love
jojo but i don't feel like because when
i see them talk about their show
i don't i don't feel like they talk
about it the way i feel about jojo you
know i think that's what every one of
those like obsessive collectors think
but the way they talk to connor in 10
years yeah right
here's my jojo toilet this could be just
taken out of context and just click with
me talking about jojo i realize that but
like when i see them there's almost like
this like like this
obsession that feels
uh unhealthy
you could probably say that you could
probably accuse me of being the same
yeah but you know when i when i just i
just like the style and i like
decorating my office in a certain way
yeah outside of that none of my rooms
are jojo you know there's nothing else
are you talking about like when
someone's entire house it's like their
entire existence becomes
a collection of this thing right and i
just wonder i'm like is that something
that just happens to anyone or is that a
thing or is it something that
maybe something's happened to you where
you you know you've had an experience or
maybe you've been raised in a certain
way
and that that makes you more receptive
to being obsessed with something i mean
what do you think i'm sure both sides
can happen but i think psychiatrists
psychologists in the chat can you let me
know i think at the end of the day it's
just about like how much do you like
this certain thing right yeah how much
are you willing to say i don't know a
part of me thinks there has to be
something where you have to be more
susceptible to addictive tendencies
uh certainly i i also think there's just
some people where for whatever reason in
their life this this one thing
means so much to them personally maybe
it came along at the right time
it helped them through something but
like they are so personally attached to
this thing yeah i'm not trying to bash
you by the way i just wanted like
actually yeah i i think i think that's
the real reason because i mean i feel
like a lot of idol fans fall into that
category where right right where you
know they they want to support these
idols because
they gave them something you know yeah
and i i i feel like that's more likely i
mean i'm sure there are a lot of people
who maybe have addictive tendencies as
well right yeah i guess because the the
the whole thing that sucks about talking
with idol uh stuff specifically is that
you know here in japan
i mean there was just some stuff that's
[ __ ] like you know there was this one
i mean the idol industry in general yeah
yeah it's it's okay what yeah there's so
much predatory [ __ ] that goes on in
there yeah and also i can't wait i don't
know if i've talked about this on trash
taste but this is one uh video on
youtube done by some abs i don't know
which news agency was it was some not
not super mainstream one they did like a
documentary with this british guy and
just goes to idol stuff yeah but not
normal idol stuff 13 year old idols
in japan
and uh man this is an uncomfortable
watch because it is like these dudes uh
go to these uh concerts with this 13
year old girl yeah and
she's dancing and stuff and uh the guy
goes around just ask these guys like hey
why do you like it and the the answers
they give are just really like
uncomfortable it's they don't say it
they don't say what you you know what
i'm thinking yeah but but they don't
really give a good argument as to not
that
there's actually there's a really good
documentary i saw i think it's on
netflix called tokyo idols yeah i've
seen that one
yeah but that one wasn't that bad
because that that i i really like that
one because i felt like it wasn't an
insulting look into it yeah that was
like an actual like in depth but at the
same time i was trying to give a i would
say an unbiased look yeah yeah yeah i i
think that was just interesting yeah i i
watched it and like you watch it and you
don't you don't really wanna you don't
judge any of the people there yeah it's
just like to me it's just fascinating
yeah yeah right how someone ends up in
this situation where he you know they
spend thousands and thousands of yeah if
you want to give if you're a 40 year old
man and you want to give thousands of
dollars to a 20 year old woman that's
fine by me yeah i got no qualms about
that you know
you can do that that's your that's your
money you do what you want with it yeah
but like the one where it was like 13 i
was like come on yeah come on i mean i
haven't seen that video i should watch
it i'll send you a link later it's just
like oh my god dude and it's just like
it's so obvious what's going on and yeah
it's not a good look yeah this is one of
those things where it's like
some idol guy was like man these guys
are making so much money off these idols
child idols and it's like no no no no oh
my god
yeah i mean like even if you don't mean
it in that way that everyone's thinking
like it's it doesn't help it really is
not a good look i feel yeah but like
like especially living in japan i feel
like japan as a country more than like
any other country that i've seen or been
to like i i understand the word otaku
here because there are so many like
really obscure things that people just
get obsessed with yeah and like it's
it's it's there's no like definite
pattern in it but like
we talk about anime ataku's but that's
like the most i'd say the most broad
otaku there is in japan because you mean
you meet people who are obsessed with
like really strange things that's almost
the most normal otaku yeah yeah it is
right yeah
because like you look like a strange
addiction you look at these like sand
eating otakus
that's why it comes that's why it comes
to my mind because i feel like somebody
who eats the stuffing in their mattress
which is the real thing by the way i i
assume i assume tlc is 100 it's
rock-solid with their journalism and
this is yeah that was an accurate yeah
of course um i'm sure some of the stuff
on tlc has staged um some
probably most of it but yeah um you know
people who do the weird thing where they
like eat only fries yeah you know i feel
like that's that's got to be some sort
of
similarity to somebody who's obsessed
with uh a certain thing that dominates
their whole life i feel there's a big
difference between an obsession and an
addiction you know whatever yeah i feel
i feel like
you know when you are
something is your identity you know it
is an addiction in some senses i think
like obsession addiction an addiction to
jojo
this just sounds like an invention
let's make it clear isn't it an
addiction or is it an upset i'm obsessed
with the style of jojo
i am not addicted to jo i don't that
sounds like denial
day by day i don't think about jojo's i
don't do anything to do with you really
you're you're addicted
i can i cannot watch i don't i can just
quit any time listen i don't suck [ __ ]
every day right
you're not looking for the next one
where is it
i i i can i don't think about jojo most
days
like a right right
this sounds like i mean yeah i don't
think about it most days okay i just i
love this style i love it in my room and
the suits are banging straight up fire
you can't deny it okay yeah like even if
you don't like jojo those suits are fire
you know what i mean right yeah if the
shoot looked like [ __ ] i wouldn't buy it
but it looks fire no it does i'm not i'm
not denying that i'm not denying that
now that being said
if i suddenly became uh just i
everything about my life was jojo i only
ever wore jojo things i wouldn't stop
talking about jojo
gone i know what you're gonna say there
was a phase in my life where i i did
only talk about jojo that was a short
period when i got into it and i'm not
proud of it i've changed for the better
intervention god told me to stop i did
i'm a changing man
if only every jojo fan could be able
but also you know
at the same time i i think i'm like okay
i see these people who have these very
severe addictions or something and i
think okay
maybe something has gone wrong maybe it
hasn't
but at the end of the day i don't really
care you you seem happy you're not
hurting anyone do what you want that's
that's how i ultimately that's what it
comes down to but i am just fascinated
of how one becomes addicted to something
like that severely you know what i mean
i'm not trying to bash on it i want to
make that clear i'm not trying to say oh
it's [ __ ] up or anything i just want
to know the process because
i feel like because it's not a super
normal thing to do because it's not
something that happens every day to
everyone yeah what happens to make
someone super addicted to something i
just want to know
a strange addiction
it's always about the strange addiction
not how it became my strange addiction
i just think like especially in japan
it's part of the reason why japan is
such a gold mine for content right it's
just because kind of kind of like so
many people are so many are into so many
niche things because when you when you
make people have to uh become so goddamn
normal and so assimilated in society
anyone is dying to do anything different
yeah i think that's why we get so many
these niche and crazy there's so many
like niche bars and places which you
know some some you've been to some are
still out there probably like we
we're like to be famous to be found
because their entire childhood their
creativity's snuffed out yeah they don't
get to be creative sure so when they
become an adult and they they can make
money and they can live their life you
know finally it's that epiphany they can
they can take control it can be
different yeah yeah yeah yeah and i i
think that's part of like the last part
of the interesting thing about living in
japan is you walk down the street
somewhere and you just you find this
random place and you're like what the
who made this who yeah what what like
only in japan
a lot of things are only in japan living
here you just become to have such an
appreciation for people who
really do just don't give a [ __ ] and
love what they want here because my god
life is hard here if you don't conform
yeah you don't do what everyone else is
doing yeah if you're the one sticking
out yes
and so when i saw that that guy rocking
all his american attire i thought
[ __ ] man the balls on this man thank god
thank god he had a good pair of denim
jeans to contain those those giant balls
you know he rocked up to a japanese
train station wearing that like that man
did not give a single [ __ ] what people
thought hell yeah and it makes you kind
of happy because you're like this man
doesn't give a [ __ ] what anyone else my
mind's japan it's funny because every
like since moving to japan and living in
japan my standard for what's become cool
and badass has just become so much so
warped compared to like when i was
living when i was living elsewhere
because i remember this i remember this
one time it was like
it was like a busy street in like
shinjuku right and uh and we were we
were all just like standing there
waiting for the lights to change and
then one guy i i i'm walking right
behind this one guy and and uh he's
walking towards his massive crowd and
like the lights are still red doesn't
even flinch doesn't even stop just
[ __ ] walks and jay and jay walks and
i'm just like
what a badass
the emotion like
the emotion that i and this is going to
be accurate you know at the end of
shawshank redemption when uh dufresne
finally breaks free yeah that's how it
feels whenever a japanese man doesn't
conform yeah the son of a [ __ ]
son of a [ __ ] crawled through the mile
long pile of [ __ ] to do it
god damn i'm like he saw the red light
that says not walked and he it didn't he
didn't even phase him he said [ __ ] this
he said [ __ ] the system i'm just like
[ __ ] me man that's a badass and i'm just
like [ __ ] that my my status for badass
is so warped living here because like
you see that in england and i'm just
like oh it's just not a [ __ ] guy yeah
that's the key to living in japan right
is to live in japan and get all the good
things and not piss anyone off yeah
we're not saying to break the rules in
japan to be a badass don't do that
do whatever the [ __ ] you want like as
long as you're not hurting anyone and
you're not breaking any rules do what
you want yeah japan is such a depressing
place if you follow every single goddamn
my new rule yeah that doesn't need to be
followed yeah but that's the thing right
and i feel that's why japan is one of
those few countries that does birth some
of the the craziest looking and the
craziest acting and just like the most
like unique type of people because
you need to be like that in order to
[ __ ] feel like you're living
sometimes it's it's weird because it
seems like it's either one way or the
other it's such an extreme right which
is why like whenever i like japan's
famous for having like very low crime
rates right but for some reason whenever
you hear about a crime being committed
here it's the most it's a [ __ ] crime
the most [ __ ] up demented [ __ ] i've
like ever heard like what the [ __ ] yeah
it's like the other day it happened
right on the auto queue line the yeah
guy who like went on and just like
stabbed 10 people because he was like i
just wanted to and i'm like she's like
the women are happy right yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's like i wanted to stab happy
women i'm like
what
what what like just just [ __ ] rub a
like hold up a corner shop or something
man like you you never hear about
someone like holding up like a corner
shop
you know like something's simple
i just said there's just so many people
who like idolize uh japan in that way
and i think you know you have to be
realistic about it like i remember i saw
i was with chris and there was this uh
he was on facebook reading an article or
something yeah there was a post someone
made on facebook was like did you know
japan has the least amount of exams in
the world and it was like yeah but only
for a specific age group and then they
[ __ ] them to death with exams yeah they
literally ruin their life they don't get
to do anything other than exam and study
like it's like oh great great they get
to have one year where they get to run
around the fields and have fun and then
we [ __ ] them today
you know it's
you know the amount of pressure on
people to succeed in exams here i don't
know anyone who went to a [ __ ] cram
school in the uk
are you kidding me i don't even have
cram i'm sure there is one i don't know
where it is i don't know anyone else who
went to one
most people had a private tutor once a
week or something like that yeah and
even then it was like wow you have a
premium
you know there is a lot of
harsh realities about japan that is
overlooked because we wanted to be this
rosy and beautiful place that is which
it is
aspects
you know i feel like we're looking where
we're lucky enough to
not have to be part of the japanese
system
we avoid the probably some of the worst
aspects of working in japan yeah you
know i think uh we work in japan in the
most comfortable way ever yeah and we're
working right now
i can just sit on my ivory tower looking
down on all these peasants and telling
them oh you should stop doing that
that's not good
you should try working from home
have you heard of that
[Music]
well yeah i saw wasn't that a new hip
thing with the young people well wasn't
there a thing where they wanted to get
people to come back into work yeah and
like a lot of workers like please god no
we want to keep teleworking yeah yeah
yeah we've discovered the beauty of that
is teleworking yeah i mean i feel like
it's if anyone was going to love
teleworking it was going to be japan
yeah oh yeah oh my god it's like this is
it's it's kind of like mind-blowing that
has taken this long for them to adopt it
honestly have you been on a japanese
zoom call
yeah unfortunately oh my god have you
been on mum yeah i have oh my god i was
like whoa where's the fun guys come on
talk a little bit like no one said
anything i got on the call we were there
for like five minutes and no one said
anything because they were waiting for
one more person yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're all just standing there with our
cameras on i was like ah
so the summer right now am i in there
like please please i'm not i'm just like
please someone talk about the weather
just just just talk about the weather
please like i know it's been basic as
[ __ ] i felt like i was waiting for my
turn to go on a game show or something
like everyone was just nervous like no
one said anything and then even then it
was like everyone would like someone
would say something i don't know how
i've been on zoom calls with like
americans and so much more chill yeah
obviously because i'm you know whatever
but i remember there was
one call i had and there was five of us
and one person would say something and
they would just wait like 30 seconds
like process it and they would be like
and i'd be like
i'm like guys this is this is in a
courtroom this is a [ __ ] zoom call no
i saw you know they would uh in america
they would publish some of the a lot of
the
zoom core proceedings yeah and i said
that was there was more more jovial fun
going on in those than on these zoom
calls that i was having
i would just stand there it would be
sorry about jovial more more
more fun
the judge is like guilty jk
just a few few jokes cracked here and
there if you uh you know even the judge
would be like how's the day going how
good good good anyway yeah so this is
far proceeding number you know anyway
i just thought i used the weirdest thing
that there was just like this weird
understanding that no one was allowed to
talk until everybody got on the zoom
call yeah like no
if they were because
according to procedure then it's just
chaos and panic yeah i was just like
this is the this is the most
like unfunded zoom call of my life
not that zoom chords will fight another
guy not the zoom calls are fine but i
didn't expect it to be like all right
i'm waiting for my hostage person to
tell my family about how much they're
gonna ask a ransom i'm waiting for the
godfather to enter the room
yeah it felt like something uh like
there was some kind of like like
spiritual ritual about to take place and
no one's talking it
so strange i was like what is this